[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe tout le monde va
bien ils ont reçu un appel d'après eux
il ya des problèmes chez nous d'accord
d'accord vous voulez aller jeter un oeil
ce n'est pas vraiment un temps pour
s'entraîner les filles n'ont pas des
devoirs à faire elles font leurs devoirs
tenait première de sa classe tout comme
line et charme ça m'ennuie pas que vous
disiez qu'on est dur avec elle vous
savez pourquoi parce qu'on l'est
c'est notre boulot ne pas les laisser
traîner dans la rue
vous voulez qu'on parle des filles
parlons des filles on a des futurs
médecins des figures avocate et deux
futures stars du tennis dans cette
maison je vais être sincère avec vous
les chances de réussite du projet dans
vos cordes et sont vraiment très très
faible vous faites une belle et rare
mais tant pis pour vous
regardez les faire quelques balles
d'accord vous vous appelez comores déjà
moi sevegner chinois serena
alors qu'est ce que vous en dites
j'ai écrit un plan de 78 pages décrivant
leur entraînement avant qu'elle vienne
au monde
elles sont brillantes pourquoi j'ai
jamais entendu parler d'elles elles
viennent de kampot tout va bien ils ont
simplement pas l'habitude de voir des
gens aussi beaucoup
détendu rentrer dans le court
elle ferait peut-être mieux carrément
sortir du court histoire de se mettre à
l'abri vous avez entre les mains le
prochain michael jordan et non mon frère
désolé moi j'en vois deux
tu va franchir une nouvelle étape
c'est pas seulement toi que tu va
représenter tu va représenter toutes les
petites filles noires du groupe
serait jamais mais je suis sûr
ces gens n'ont jamais une ou un droit
respect pour mes soeurs williams mais
vous ils vous respectent ont
tu vas entrer sur le court la tête haute
j'ai une championne et le monde entier
le m
créature la plus dangereuse sur cette
planète
c'est une femme qui sait réfléchir oui
papa rien est impossible pour elle
tu va leur montrer ce que tu as dans le
ventre
venus et serena va
pour changer le monde
venus williams qui est en meilleure amie
va pas serena williams qui est ton
meilleur ami dennis en titre et faire
des gestes l'attaqué du ch'ti
[Musique]